The multi-device experiences platform, or
MDX, is an extensible cloud AI service
hosted in Azure. MDX enables research and
development on task-focused scenarios
that span multiple devices, empowering
first and third party developers to
build intelligent and interactive
experiences that capitalize on the
convenience, efficiency, and strengths of
multi device usage throughout a task. The
MDX platform, enabling research and
development in multi device experiences.
Check out how the power of MDX could
enhance even the simplest of daily tasks.
Alexa ask chef to show me that paella recipe
I looked at last night. Here is the
recipe for traditional Paella Valenciana.
All right, let's cook.
How much rice do I need? 350 grams Paia
rice. How many cups is that? It is 1-3/4 cups.
I don't have green beans. Can I
replace the green beans or something
else? Yes you could use snap peas instead.
Add green beans to my grocery list. I
have added green beans to your grocery
list.
Okay what's the next step?
Pour in about a liter of the chicken
stock.
Are there any wines that would pair well
with this recipe? How about a chilled dry
Rosatto from Navarra?
Can you let me know when this step is
done? I'll start a 10-minute timer for you.
Ten minutes is up. Time for the next step.Thanks MDX